[Music]
thank you
hey Jacques thanks for sending me that
video I think this might just be the
Pokemon I've been hearing so much about
trainers from all over of reported
sightings
gotta say Professor I'm surprised gimme
Gould's showing up in your neck of the
woods
[Music]
migor so that's what this Pokemon's
called
Treasure Chest it hides in actually be
part of its body
it also carries the same type of coin
trainers have been finding that's right
in paudia I've seen some gimme ghoul
that hide in treasure chests and some
that don't
hmm
the ones hiding in chests are new to me
the fascinating part is as far as I know
no one's ever caught a gimme ghoul
that's not in a chest the second you get
near they hightail it out of there
dropping a coin as they flee
I don't think we've seen them act like
that over here
[Music]
you know there's actually an interesting
story about gimmigo and its coins
[Music]
[Applause]
here's an old strange tale involving a
mysterious coin
[Music]
once upon a time a young girl was out on
a walk when she picked up a coin
clink
there's another said the girl wait
what's that
when the mysterious being noticed the
girl it fled through a nearby door
the girl hurriedly chased after it and
Came Upon a treasure chest
but the mysterious being lurked nearby
staring intently at the girl
the treasure chest opened quietly and
whatever was inside met the girl's gaze
the girl put a coin into the treasure
chest
she picked up another coin and put it
into the chest
two once again she picked up a coin and
put it into the chest
three
[Music]
eventually the chest came to be full of
coins
997
998 999.
[Music]
thank you
huh what am I doing with all these coins
the girl wondered now who or what had
been so intent on Gathering them
[Applause]
intriguing tail it might help us learn
more about this Pokemon
I hope so it seems to suggest that give
me go hiding in treasure chests don't
move on their own they just manipulate
people into Gathering coins for them
on the other hand gimme ghoul without
treasure chests don't seem to manipulate
people
perhaps they're able to go searching on
their own
it's very odd for Pokemon of the same
species to behave so differently don't
you think since they're behaving so
differently maybe we ought to consider
them separate forms what do you think
should we name them
good idea let's see chest form seems
fair for the one that hides in chess
that's very straightforward as for the
one that walks around how about roaming
form
I like it so you've never heard of
anyone catching a roaming form gimme
ghoul in paldeo right
yep but out where you are they don't run
away
you said they just tag along near people
who picked up coins
all right if trainers out here use that
behavior to their advantage they might
be able to catch it what an exciting
research opportunity is there anything
else you can tell me about gimme Gould
I'd be happy to tell you everything I
know and I'll do what I can to help you
catch roaming form gimme ghoul
thank you and I'm sure trainers will
also appreciate your help now about
those coins
uh whoops there's the bell time for
class sorry professor
gotta run before you go
oh well that's Jacques for you always
dancing to the beat of his own drum how
to send him a thank you gift for his
help with gimme ghoul maybe a nice
postcard
[Music]